[Music]
actor Chuck Norris and his wife Gina are
now suing several medical companies
after they say that she was poisoned by
a drug used during a routine MRI scan
the drug is a contrast agent it enhances
MRI images and helps with the diagnosis
Anna Warner is here with a look at the
debate surrounding these drugs and why
the doctors say they are part of an
essential tool box that is used to save
lives and a good morning good morning
the companies that make contrast agents
say they are safe and have been used to
aid in the treatment of millions of
patients but the Norris's aren't the
only ones complaining about side effects
from the routine medical procedure gina
norris in particular hopes their lawsuit
brings more attention to the issue in
movies Chuck Norris fought martial arts
masters but now he's taking on medical
companies along with his wife Gina I
couldn't think anymore any type of
cognition being able to articulate my
memory I had muscle wasting she says she
was poisoned after a routine MRI
nothing's going on here she's dying
she's dying right in front of me here at
this hospital
MRIs help doctors diagnose disease by
taking pictures inside the body
sometimes doctors inject a drug called a
contrast agent during the procedure to
get sharper images the Norris has blame
a gadolinium-based contrast agent for
her health problems saying in their
lawsuit that she developed gadolinium
deposition disease with symptoms
including burning pain violent shaking
and confusion along with kidney damage
Norris attorney Todd Walters we have
clients who have been misdiagnosed with
lyme disease ALS and then they've
eventually ruled all those things out
and and the culprit remaining is the
gadolinium drug distributor McKesson
said it's reviewing the complaint and
will respond in a timely manner the
maker of the drug said it takes patient
safety very seriously and stands behind
the safety of all its products CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus what
we know is that gadolinium this dye
that's used
and actually deposit in tissue that's
known now what we don't know is that it
actually is associated with symptoms in
patients dr. agus says he doesn't want
patients to be scared of a test that
could save their life
these are critical tests and I don't
want worry initially without real
substantive data to actually stress
people out Gena Norris agrees we don't
want to see that go away then I mean it
saves you know countless lives and that
needs to stay but she says had she
thought there were risks she would not
have allowed the drug to be used for all
those people that are thinking about
getting an MRI there needs to be some
stricter warnings well the FDA started
looking at this in 2015 and earlier this
year said it had not identified any
harmful effects from gadolinium that
stayed in the brain but in September an
advisory committee did vote to change
the drug labels to warn that some of the
chemical may remain in certain organs
including the brain and recommended risk
minimization steps for specific more
sensitive patient populations so I think
the jury's still out but at least it's
something that patients can talk to
their doctors about Horn MRI of it
especially if you have kidney issues
then you really want to talk to your
doctor about it and I thank you